but we begin with chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel on Capitol
Hill with the latest on efforts to pass
that big budget deal to keep the
government open good evening Mike Chris
good evening the Senate is in a bit of a
holding pattern as Kentucky Senator Rand
Paul is on the Senate floor this hour
protesting this budget agreement
breaking existing spending caps there
was a bit of an effort a moment ago by
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell and
Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
to see if Senator Paul would move things
along noting the time is getting short
but Senator Paul objected he is making
his case on the Senate floor now ahead
of votes in the Senate and eventually
the House
there has been some serious pushback but
I have this much of an increase in
spending and almost nothing in the way
of pay-fors it's for me very problematic
we're very disheartened by this
disagreement partisanship it seems the
only thing we could do partisan way
deficit hawks expressed their disgust
the two-year budget package includes 165
billion dollars more in spending on the
military any problem
Democrats demanded 131 billion dollars
more nearly dollar-for-dollar in
domestic spending and it raises the debt
ceiling through March 2019 he is
concerned about spending in Washington
he's expressed that for years let me
just say off the bat we do support the
two-year spending bill that is being
discussed and voted on in the House and
Senate you know he lifts the caps on
defense spending the package includes
ninety billion dollars in disaster
relief money for hurricane victims in
Texas Florida and Puerto Rico and money
for wildfire victims in California
Senate leaders focused on getting it
done I'm confident that no senator on
either side of the aisle believes this
is perfect bill but I'm also confident
this is our best chance to begin
rebuilding our military and make
progress on issues directly affecting
the American people a leading Senate
Democrat called this two-year budget a
breakthrough for too long this gridlock
Congress has lurched from one continuing
resolution that's a temporary spending
bill to another that's
prevented us from working together to
craft appropriations bills that save
taxpayers money on the house side
Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi actually
negotiated the agreement but spoke out
against it because a deal for the
so-called dreamers is not included all
out there let the house work its will
but don't say to the house we remove
your dignity as your role in this
important an issue that is being
discussed throughout the country needing
Democrat votes Speaker Paul Ryan tried
to reassure Pelosi's rank-and-file
members to anyone who doubts my
intention to solve this problem and
bring up a daca and immigration reform
bill do not we will bring a solution to
the floor one that the president will
sign we must pass this budget agreement
first though so that we can get on to
that the stakes are very high if
lawmakers stumble we could be heading
for our second partial government
shutdown of 2018 and it's just February
Chris Mike Emanuel on Capitol Hill will
come back to you for any more
developments Mike thank you